you open your book love and math with a
question
how does one become a mathematician
there are many ways that this can happen
let me tell you how it happened to me so
how did it happen to you so first of all
I grew up in the Soviet Union
in a small town near Moscow
called columna
and I was a smart kid you know in school
but mathematics was probably my least
favorite subject
not because I couldn't do it I was you
know a straight A student and I could do
all the problems easily but I thought it
was incredibly boring
and
um since the only math I knew was what
was presented at school
I thought that was it and I was like
what kind of boring subject is this so
what I really liked was physics
and especially quantum physics so I was
buying uh I was I would go to a
bookstore and buy popular books about
elementary particles
and atoms and things like that and read
them you know devour them
and so I thought my dream was to become
a theoretical physicist
and to delve into this finer structure
of the universe you know so then
something happened when I was 15 years
old uh it turns out that a friend of my
parents
was a mathematician who was a professor
at the local College it was a small
College preparing Educators teachers
it's a provincial Town imagine it's like
a 117 kilometers from Moscow which would
be something like 70 miles I guess you
do the math I like how you remember the
number exactly yeah it's not funny how
we remember numbers yeah so his name was
evgeny evgenievich Petrov yeah and if
this doesn't remind you of the great
works of Russian literature then you
haven't read them
like War and Peace you know like with
the patronym nicknames but this was all
real this was all happening so my mom
One Day by chance met ige and told him
about me
but that was this bright kid and
interested in physics
and he said oh I want to meet him I'm
going to convert him into math
and my mom's like nah mask he doesn't
like mathematics so they said okay let's
let's see what they can do
so I went to see him so I'm about 15.
and a bit a bit uh arrogant I would say
you know like average teenager
so he says to me
so I hear that you are
um interested in in physics Elementary
particles it's like yeah sure
and so for example do you know about
quarks
and I said yes of course I know what
quarks quarks are the you know
constituents
of particles like protons and neutrons
and it was one of the greatest
discoveries in theoretical physics in
the 60s that those particles were not
Elementary but in fact had the smaller
parts
and he said oh so then you probably know
representation theory of the group su3
this is like I see words so
in fact
I wanted to know what was what were the
underpinnings of those theories I knew
the story I knew the narrative a new
kind of this basic story of what this
particles looked like but how did
physicists come up with these ideas
how were they able to theorize them
and so I remembered you know like it was
yesterday so he pulls out a book
and it's kind of like like a Bible you
know like like a substantial book and he
opens them somewhere in the middle and
there I see the diagrams that I saw in
popular books but in popular books there
was no explanation and now I see all
these weird symbols and equations it's
clear that it is explained in there oh
my God
he said you think what they teach you at
school is mathematics
it's like no this is real mathematics
so I was instantly converted
that you understand the underpinnings of
physical reality
you have to understand what su3 is you
have to learn what are groups what this
group su3 what are representations of
sc3 there was a coherent
and beautiful I could appreciate the
beauty even though I could not
understand
heads and tails of it but you were drawn
to the the methodology the
the the Machinery of all such
understanding could be attained well in
retrospect I think what I was really
craving was a deeper understanding
and up to that point the deepest that I
could see was for those diagrams but for
that story that you know a proton
consists of three quarks and the neutron
consists of trick works and they're
called up and down and so on
but I didn't know
that there was actually underneath
beneath the surface there was this
mathematical theory if you can just link
around it what Drew you to quantum
mechanics
is there some romantic notion of
understanding the universe well what is
interesting to you is it the puzzle of
it or is it like the philosophical thing
now I am looking back yeah so um
whatever I say about Edward at 15 yeah
is colored by
uh my you know all my experiences that
happen in in the meantime I should say
current views and so on for the people
who may not know you I think your book
and your presentations kind of revealed
that that 15 year old is still in there
somewhere well hmm
yeah I think it was a joy of Discovery
and the joy of going deeper into the
kind of the
uh to the root uh to the so the deepest
structures of the universe the secrets
the the secrets and we may not discover
all of them we may not be able to
understand but we're going to try and go
as far and as deep as we can I think
that's what was the motivating factor in
this
yeah there's this mystery there's this
dark room and there's a few of these
mathematical physicists they're able to
shine
a flashlight briefly into there
uh we'll we'll talk about it but it also
kind of makes me sad that there's so few
of your kind that have the the
flashlight to look into the room
it's interesting
um I don't think there are so few to be
honest because I think I find a lot of
people are actually interested if you do
talk if you talk to people you know like
some people you wouldn't expect to uh to
be interested in this uh from all walks
of life from people of
all kinds of professions I tell them I'm
a mathematician and the mathematician
okay so that's a separate story a lot of
people I think have been traumatized by
their experience in their math classes
we can talk about it later but then they
ask me what kind of research I do and
I I mentioned that I I work on the
interface of math and quantum physics
and their eyes light up and say oh
quantum physics or like Einstein's
relativity I'm really curious about it I
watched this podcast or I watch that
podcast you know and I've learned this
it's like what do you think about that
so I actually find that that actually
physicists are doing great job at
educating
the public so to speak and uh in terms
of
um
popular books and videos and so on
mathematicians are behind that we're
starting to catch up a little bit have
been starting last 10 years but when
we're still behind but I think people
are people are curious
science is a is still a very much uh you
know something that people want to learn
because that's our kind of uh the best
way we know to establish some sort of
objective reality whatever that might be
yeah to figure out this whole puzzle to
figure out the secrets that the Universe
holds things that we can agree on kind
of you know like even though for me at
this point I always you know make an
argument that our physical theorists
always change they get updated so you
had Newton's theory of gravity
then um Einstein's theory you know
superseded it
but in mathematics
it seems that theories don't change
Pythagoras Theorem
has been the same for the last 2500
years x squared plus y squared equals z
squared we don't expect that next year
suddenly it will be z cubed you know so
and so that to me is actually even more
um hints even more at home how how much
we are connected to each other because
dagger's theory if you think about it or
any other mathematical theorem
means the same thing to anyone in the
world today regardless of their cultural
you know bringing uh religion you know
ideas ideal ideology gender whatever
nationality race whatever right and it
has meant the same to everyone
everywhere and most likely will mean the
same
so that's to me kind of an antidote
to the kind of
divisiveness that we sometimes observe
these days where it seems that we can't
agree on anything
to the political complexity of uh two
plus two equals five and George Orwell's
1984. I was in the Soviet Union in 1984
and so in many ways I see that it was
President the novel was present but we
still have not found the dictator who
would actually say two plus two equals
five and would demand their citizens to
repeat that the Knight is still young
has not happened yet